on this episode I get reconnected with
an old friend I talk about self-esteem
and yoga but do you put husky everybody
this is gary vay-ner-chuk and you're
watching the askgaryvee show episode 18
the fun fact about 18 the Jets had an 18
point lead in Green Bay on Sunday and
blew it Thomas asks what forms of media
do you consume and are there any
particular people you listen to Thomas
how are you thank you for the opening
question on episode 18 a little bit of
better mood for me than 17 uh I consume
a lot of Twitter predominantly a little
bit of Facebook newsfeed a little bit of
espn.com I actually consume a shockingly
low percentage of media and as it comes
to following people who do I listen to
again I really don't really pay
attention to a whole lot of taste makers
or notable figures I'm very within I'm
very selfishly stuck in my cocoon but
this is we're going to throw you for a
curveball and I do think it's a
differentiator I spend an obnoxious
heavy amount of time listening to my
community
last night after lots of meetings right
before bed instead of consuming stuff as
the normal marketplace does I was
reading the comments that a lot of you
left for me in yesterday's episode it is
more interesting to me to understand
what my the people that I'm lucky enough
to give me their attention what they're
looking for from me a little bit about
their life I know that chef Lizette is
moving to New York I'm consuming my
community which i think is me repaying
what you're paying me with which is your
attention I'm giving you back my
attention and so I haven't anchored
myself maybe out of pride or bravado or
ego to other tastemakers or leaders I
don't do that at all
it keeps me fresh in some way it
continues to allow me to be in my lingo
and I don't really want to be affected
I'm very in my zone so my consumption is
quite low I read Tech mean Jason
Hirschhorn email for like what's in the
news but I'm not consuming much and I'm
not following much except for you Gary
should I still pursue a degree in
marketing when you say even though you
say marketers ruin everything I'm a
marketer if not if not then what should
I pursue in regards to my career because
I really want to work in marketing but
approach it differently than it's been
done in the past their lawyers
Jen uh first and foremost I like how you
were reading some sort of card over here
I'd eliminate that from your game but
I'm not razzing um
marketers do ruin everything and I'm a
proud and happy marketer so don't take
that literally I think you should pursue
marketing and I love that you're trying
to look the fact that you even know who
I am and are asking a question on the
askgaryvee show believe it or not makes
me think you're going to be successful
and what I would recommend is the
degrees nice and all but I would highly
recommend if you're still in university
to intern at the places that you most
think are innovating I mean when I think
about the last two classes of
vaynermedia interns and the fact how
many of them get hired into this
organization and how great vaynermedia
is as an organization by comparison to
the other people that are marketing as
agencies out there and I really believe
that I think they were very smart
strategic and made the right move I
would give you the same recommendation
get into the walls that you most believe
in and you should mark it in a different
way and 99% of the places right now
won't allow you to do that so find the
other five six seven ten places that
look like this place which will create
the culture to allow that Carlos asks
curious how you feel about the impact
you've made on people you've touched and
inspired over the years Carlos thank you
so much for that question it's very
sweet but you know a lot of you really
know me because you've been following my
career for quite a while and we interact
quite a bit and I think I'm more
tangibly untouchable than a lot of the
other kind of people that look like me
and we engage quite a bit and I have a
lot of context back to question number
one in comparison to others and all that
blah blah blah but the truth is mostly
don't really really really know me and I
think that you know with the with the
hustler and businessman and they and the
North Star of buying the New York Jets
one would say he loves and wants to buy
the Jets more than anything and thus the
money associated with that process is
very important to him it is a distant
second to know that I've been gifted
with a communication style that touches
people that makes them you know maybe
I'm saying the same thing they've heard
before
it's either Mike
diction or it comes from my soul in such
a way I talk about what I believe in so
much that it's been able to move people
crush it was clearly a catalyst because
that book really did move people's
career so many of you have been affected
it blows my mind actually to think about
how many people have been affected even
in small ways creating more positivity
for some people there's just so many
variables of how I've affected people
and I don't see that in like look at how
cool I am I'm just so goddamn thankful
you know it's you know so how do I think
about it I think it is my legacy I think
it is the essence of who I am as a human
being and it is the singular thing that
I'm most proud of and it gives me
enormous confidence of what kind of
parent I'm going to be and that makes me
very very happy
so you know gary vay-ner-chuk I know my
question for you is this um do you speak
Russian da Yaga voodoo Peru ski knickers
a lot is Nigeria ho America Creole 3 god
so mami Papa had silly beats American
ski in New Guinea Peru ski Ojinaga but
yeah stills narcotics cover deeds
EF sua Chopin Amaya and for all of you
that don't understand that that was
Russian with a very heavy
English accent predicated on the notion
that it was important for my parents to
become Americanized and so we didn't
live in Brooklyn and Brighton Beach with
all the other Russians we went to New
Jersey we were very proud to become
Americans and very much pushed English
language in the home mrs. Jones asks how
do you make sure lack of competence
doesn't stop me from chasing my dreams
mrs. Jones this is a very important
question to me because I'm actually
quite scared to give you the answer
which is we need to seriously think
about how to build up your confidence I
am the kind of person that believes that
self-esteem is the ultimate drug in
society and I believe that when you have
self-esteem you give yourself your
gastly to dream big
ok buy the New York Jets
when you dream big what ends up
happening is the little things stop
mattering as much and you're not
crippled by them and you start really
kind of becoming you know I'm actually
maybe the least anxious person I know in
a world where anxiety should be on paper
the thing that I most have because I
have so much going on and I have these
enormous aspirations you know I really
struggle with this question because I
would actually tell you to not say well
don't worry about it you'll get there
and no rah-rah I can do real quick here
is going to affect you but what I'm
hoping to affect you with is I would
highly recommend doing some deep
searching into what you can afford and
what is practical to work on that
whether that's literally seeing somebody
to build it up mapping your life
backwards surrounding yourself with
positive self-esteem driven people I
think is a very unique way to do it this
is the big one for me fellas and ladies
I am uh I am all-in on self-esteem and
and I would say if you are self-aware
enough to know that you lack it I would
tell you to execute about finding a way
to gain more of it bury love in the show
like loving it Greg see you back I hope
you remember me from Wine Library
episode seven five nine where we drank
out of bottles I remember that my
question and I've got a video blog in my
mood calm plug the plug in as and get
about 5,000 views a week but we've been
kind of there for the last 200 or so
episodes and should I click on sure be
bothered about that we're getting sales
from it we get lots of interaction from
it but should I click on it if I am
should I look a dark post should I look
at Twitter
what should I kind of do to kind of find
that next level and thank you for the
show my pleasure my friend I definitely
definitely remember remember you and
that was a lot of fun uh you know it's
funny I was just about to segue in
closing out the show about I also want
more viewers and I want to keep building
like when you're in the game you're in
the game you want to build uh and you've
done the patience thing which is
normally my answer that's my answer to
me I'm only 18 episodes in and you got a
reach
on a rebuilding audience and get people
used to behavior and it's not email or
RSS like I had with Wine Library Becca
note six seven eight and so it's
different ways its Twitter but that's
noisier and different you know so I
would say distribution the reason you're
stuck right now is you need distribution
distribution distribution I highly
recommend you say to yourself what are
the 100 websites that are the biggest
websites in the world that speak to our
in the genre of my show and then
literally email them one by one and ask
them if they want the rights to
distribute your content with maybe you
writing on top of it I'd also reach out
to the top 100 podcasts that you can get
out there on and promote the show give
interviews
you need the hustle what you just did by
getting on this show worked you are
going to pick up thirty nine forty to
seventy three new listeners for your
show by being on this show and you need
to just scale the living crap out of
that it's hustle hustle hustle hustle
hustle hustle hustle hustle
but with a thread in distribution you
need more awareness you need to show up
on other YouTube celebrities show you
need to show up you need to get into the
LinkedIn community and start putting out
that content you need to get the hell
out there that is the game my friend and
that is a nice way to kind of wrap up
the show because that's what I was going
to rant about at the end question of the
day been working on it a lot of you have
answered I really appreciate your
feedback using the last episode what do
you think about the new
garyvaynerchuk.com right here right here
put some work into it we're on the back
of rebel Mouse one of my investments
apart from I really believe in and I'd
love your three cents on that you keep
asking questions I will keep answering
them
lairs baby lair and that's it
episode 18 in the books guys oh that's
not it we have one more video question
and ironically I was about to talk about
it so let's go to it